La volta al món a peu, dia 288.
És ben d'hora, són les 6 i 23.
M'ha despertat una espècie de màquina que hi ha allà, que està cegant.
Mira, just ara ha callat perquè faci el vídeo.
Bé, nit freda, però bona nit.
I mira, m'he despertat amb una visió de muntanyes nevades.
Aquí suposo que va nevar, petita capa, allà al fons, allà és direcció Murgap.
D'allà veníem, i sí, sí, hi ha una mica de neu, no?, pel que sembla.
I cap a l'altra banda no ho veig perquè hi ha el sol que em fa contrallum.
Molt bé, tu.
Avui, 46 quilòmetres, està bé que m'hagi llevat d'hora perquè serà un dia intens de carretera.
I ara, com que no hi ha capa, m'he despertat amb una visió de muntanyes nevades.
Les 10 menys 20, 3 hores de marxa i gairebé 15 quilòmetres.
Ha parat una mica aquí.
El dia està bé, eh?
No fa res.
No fa gens de vent, puc anar amb mania curta.
Hi ha molt poc trànsit, però, ostres, la carretera, el paviment, si algun dia n'hi va haver, ha desaparegut.
Llavors, hi ha aquests sots i tal, hi ha pedres, i paral·lelament a la carretera hi ha un camí que és suposo nou.
L'han fet els camions d'anar recorrent, i paral·lelament a aquest camí hi ha un altre camí, no?
I es van fent paral·lels a mesura que es va fent malbé, per tant, trànsit de camions.
Horrible per conduir i per venir amb bicicleta, eh?, aquesta carretera.
A més, hi ha alguns llocs que s'aixequen moltíssim a pols.
Mira, ara ve un cotxe.
Bueno, porra de tu, un descansillo, a menjar alguna cosa i després seguir.
Per cert, allà que hi havia la neu aquella, a les muntanyes, ja s'ha desfet.
Amb el sol aquest, ha durat poc.
Uau, estic veient dos tornados.
Si això fos el mar, es diria...
Gló, no?
Són tornados de pols, no?
Flipa, eh?
I mira que no fa vent, eh, ara mateix.
Que guapo.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, sembla que hi ha una tempesta de sorra.
Hi ha un mur de sorra que està avançant cap a mi.
No!
Doncs, les dues i set, trenta quilòmetres ja.
Molt bé, molt bé, bon ritme.
Estic bé.
Millor que ahir, eh?
Us vaig dir que em faltava l'aire?
avui no tant
no sé, és igual
bueno, què hi ha de novetat
a part d'això
al fons veig unes muntanyes
nevades, he tret l'aplicació
que em diu el nom de les muntanyes
n'hi ha diverses, jo faig servir el Peak Finder
però si tens la versió Pro
del MAPI també t'ho diu
doncs aquelles muntanyes del fons ja són Xina
sí, sí, ja són la Xina
de fet, per arribar a Culmapàs
només queden 42 quilòmetres
segons el Morreotge
i per acabar el dia d'avui queden 16
per tant anem bé
sembla que
no em pitjorarà la cosa més que
algun núvol
som-hi
vinga Avui
Fins al final
Queden 6 quilòmetres per arribar al
pàrquing aquest de camions
que en teoria dormo
ja el veig aquí en principi
crec que és allò
Tinc una antena de 3G aquí darrere que no em serveix per posar el vídeo,
però per parlar i obrir el WhatsApp sí.
Oh, l'aire és tan fred que em costa parlar.
Bé, i aquí tenim un lletrero, un cartell que diu que...
Bé, no sé què, el típic cartell d'obra, no?, de construcció d'una carretera.
Diu que és la carretera que es va acabar l'1 de novembre del 2000
i, pel que tinc entès, veieu, no?,
veieu que aquí sí que està ben asfaltat i allà ja es veu ben asfaltat?
No sé per què.
Aquí van fer la carretera fins a la Xina, suposo,
i aquest tram d'aquí fins a Murgap,
doncs se l'han deixat de la Magadeu, doncs mira, ho celebro.
Aquí hi ha una intersecció que si obres el mapa
i mires on va, va al no-res.
Si aquesta carretera, no és la que agafaré jo, eh?,
però va al no-res,
hi ha un parell de pobles allà que jo no entenc la gent com viu allà,
és que no hi ha absolutament res, bueno,
es deuen ser militars, no?, que estan allà per controlar la frontera,
perquè això va a la frontera amb Afganistan,
el famós corredor de Wuhan, es diu, el corredor de no sé què.
Bé, no ho sé, tot.
Molt loco, molt loco aquest lloc.
Ara estava editant el vídeo i m'he adonat que tot el dia d'avui,
que ja són gairebé les 5, ja estic a punt d'acabar el dia,
només ha sigut 4 hores.
4 minuts de vídeo.
És que tu, no he pogut gravar res més, és que no hi havia res més a gravar.
Doncs ja gairebé he arribat.
Molt bé, 17.47, ja he fet gairebé 47 quilòmetres, és molt bona hora.
I bueno, a veure, us explico una cosa.
Veieu aquest gos que hi ha aquí al darrere?
Bé, és igual.
Allà, a uns quants quilòmetres, hi ha un checkpoint.
Un checkpoint que hauré d'anar demà i, bueno,
ensenyaré el passaport al portnís de la zona aquesta,
d'Alguebou,
i preguntaré si puc anar fins a Culmapàs caminant.
Perdoneu que em costa parlar.
A veure, jo, pel que he vist a alguns fòrums i tal,
sembla que sí, però no n'estic del tot convençut.
Jo ho intentaré, en principi, anar fins a Culmapàs caminant,
però bueno, en qualsevol cas, això ja serà demà.
Aquí què tenim?
Aquí tenim, no sé, aquí hi ha camions, contenidors, tal,
i aquí darrere meu és on,
si tu véns amb el teu vehicle a Tadjikistan i entres per Culmapàs,
has de registrar aquí el teu vehicle conforme entres a Tadjikistan.
A part d'això, veig moltíssims camions,
jo crec que també diuen per als camions, no sé, temes de les mercaderies, no sé què.
I el mapi diu que és allà on hi ha el lloc per dormir,
el suposat lloc per dormir, no sé.
El Eoverlander diu que és aquí, però jo aquí...
Aquí ja no veig res.
Bé, tu, potser és que és aquí, perquè veig una llurta aquí i el d'això,
l'Eoverlander deia que hi havia una llurta.
Clar, és que allà...
Bé, vaig a preguntar per aquí a veure què hi ha.
Doncs al final sí que era aquí, a la llurta aquesta que us he ensenyat la primera,
que des de fora sembla molt ronyosa,
però dintre està bé, ara us l'ensenyo al palauet.
I bueno, he picat, i sí, sí, m'ha sortit una família,
i la dona és professora d'anglès.
Té un anglès de sisè de primària, eh?
Primer d'això com a màxim.
Però sí, i diu, li pregunto, ets de Tadjikistan?
I diu, sí, sí, sí.
Però quina llengua parles?
I diu, no, la llengua de Kyrgyzstan.
I faig de professora d'anglès al Kyrgyzstan.
No sé, no sé molt bé com va el tema d'aquesta zona,
però estan una mica tots masclats.
Bueno, us ensenyo el piset.
Us aviso que està una mica fosc.
A veure.
Bueno, es veu prou bé.
Això no està encès, no sé si m'ho encendran.
Bueno, jo crec que no cal.
Diuen que és una llurta com l'altre dia,
una mica més petita potser,
i el llit serà això.
Però bueno, està prou bé.
Està prou bé, sempre puc posar el meu matalàs.
Allà sempre pot ser més còmode.
Pot ser que vingui algun altre camioner aquí,
perquè pel que he llegit,
aquí normalment és perquè es caiguin els camioners.
Aquí tenim el sostre, aquí.
I aquesta espècie de cubell,
doncs ni idea de per què és.
Bueno, clar,
jo estava espantat pels diners perquè ja us he dit
que no en tinc tants.
I pregunto, bueno, how much?
I diu 20 somoni.
Jo, quan he sentit la paraula 20,
he pensat 20 euros.
Després he reflexionat, no, no,
20 somoni són 2 euros.
Hòstia, 2 euros, estic salvat, estic salvat.
I dic, bueno, i menjar potser?
I diu, sí, sí, però clar, llavors seran,
no sé si m'ha dit 40 o així,
li he donat 50, li he donat 5 euros, home, t'ho diràs.
I de fet no sé què em donarà perquè m'ha dit
yak, però no sé si es referia,
si m'ha dit tu yak, però no sé si es referia
a ous, egg,
o a yak, l'animal.
No ho sé. És igual, tu.
Estic cansat. Vaig a descansar una estona.
I quan arriba el sopar,
en resum.
Bé, espero que em veieu bé.
Quan he de gravar a la nit, mai sé si se'm veu,
si se m'enfoca bé o no.
Bueno, al final no ha sigut yak, ha sigut egg.
Han sigut res.
Dos ous fregits
i una mica de pa.
Bueno, per dos euros, què més vols, no?
Llavors, clar, com
tenia més gana, t'havia
emportat te, i com el te estava calent, doncs
he aprofitat i he
posat a fer ramen, el ramen
instantani, que normalment el faig
fred, perquè no tinc fogonet, doncs mira, ara que tenia
aigua calenta, doncs he fet el ramen
amb aigua de te. I
no tenia massa sabor a te. Bé, ha quedat
bueno, bo.
Tampoc definiria com a bo aquest tipus
de menjars, però bueno.
M'han nutrit una mica més i ara ja estic
satisfet de calories.
Bueno, avui
47 quilòmetres i pico.
Bueno, avui 47 quilòmetres i pico.
M'he gastat 5 euros.
No he parlat amb ningú.
No, perquè el que he parlat amb aquesta professora
no compta.
I res, ni cap refrescs,
ni cap... Mira, un te, sí, un te.
Ha sigut un dia, mira,
millor del previst,
perquè els altres dies que havia hagut de fer 50
quilòmetres ho havia passat malament,
en el sentit de
mentalment destruït, ja us he explicat.
No, i avui millor.
Avui millor, o sigui que guai.
Guai, guai.
Bueno, a veure,
tinc aquí l'altre mòbil
que m'he apuntat a algunes coses que us vull dir.
Demà,
si tot va bé, entro a la
Xina, crevo la
frontera de Tadjikistan a Xina a
Kulmapass.
A veure,
des del punt de vista estricte
és simplement un port
de muntanya, un port de muntanya
que puges d'una valla
fins al port i bajes fins a la següent vall.
I ja està. No? Bueno,
no.
Sí, o sigui,
geogràficament és només això, però
són moltes més coses, no?
A veure, en primer lloc, serà
l'altitud màxima a la que he estat
a la meva vida, Kulmapass.
4.300 i pico metres sobre el nivell del mar.
I el màxim que he fet ha sigut 4.100
i pico al Tubkal, al Marroc, crec.
Sí.
Després, doncs,
entro a la Xina.
No és un país normal,
perquè entres a la Xina, saps?
És que hauré caminat
no tot, però gairebé
tot, excepte en aquest tram que vaig agafar
l'avió, des de Barcelona fins a la Xina.
És que és molt louc, eh?
Sempre dic que quan vas caminant
el canvi
es va produint a poc a poc, no?
Tu vas veient a poc a poc
com canviaven els paisatges, com canviaven
la gent, no? A Tajikistan la gent
donava el pamir, no el mateix que a Dushanbe, però
a poc a poc anaves veient com anava canviant.
Però les fronteres
són llocs on
on canvia radicalment.
I crec que aquesta serà una de les fronteres,
ja ho veurem demà, en la qual
el canvi serà
més bèstia perquè a Tajikistan
és, jo diria que el país més pobre
que ha estat mai.
I la Xina, doncs,
bueno, tindrà les seves coses, ja ho
veurem, no? Només estaré uns pocs dies, però
no té fama de ser
un país pobre, no ho sé.
També aquí és una zona molt particular de
la Xina. Entrarem a
Xinjiang, crec que es diu la regió.
És una regió molt vigilada
i bé,
a veure, o sigui, com ho explico?
O sigui, aquesta
regió es pot entrar des de
Kyrgyzstan o des d'aquí, també.
Però, per algun motiu,
quan tu agafes el Google
Maps, la
carretera que va fins a Kulmapas
has de fer molt, molt, molt, molt zoom
perquè et surti.
Saps que el Google Maps, com més gruixut
o més prim és la carretera, doncs més importància
li dóna, no?, si és més gruixuda.
La carretera de Kulmapas té una
importància molt petita, a pesar de que
és molt més gran la carretera aquesta que
altres caminets que van per aquí, no?
I, quan arriba a Kulmapas,
després,
a la part de la Xina, aneu a veure-ho,
obriu Google Maps, ja ho veureu,
desapareix la carretera.
És com que, és com que,
no sé, m'invento, eh?, però és com que
Xina li ha demanat a Google,
mira, aquesta frontera no la,
no la marquis gaire, saps?
No ens interessa que la gent vingui per aquí.
Si tu estàs mirant el Google Maps
per planificar un viatge, tu penses
que no hi ha frontera entre Tajikistan i Xina.
Si agafes el mapi, llavors sí,
sí que surt clarament la carretera
i tot plegat, no? Però si no, no,
és curiós. No sé si
els interessa més que la gent entri per Kyrgyzstan.
Per algun motiu, no ho sé.
Com he dit, aquesta és una
zona amb una sensibilitat especial, podríem
dir, i pel que he llegit, pot ser
que a la frontera
m'inspeccionin de dalt a baix.
La motxilla, tot el
que porto. Ítem per
ítem, i anar vigilant.
També, el motiu, suposo
que és que, clar, et diuen creuar tants pocs turistes
estrangers per aquí, que a la que agafen
un sac, no? No ho sé, no ho sé, demà
us ho explicaré, a veure què tal.
Però una altra cosa és això, que pugui passar.
No sé, potser em diuen no, no.
Potser no em deixaran entrar a la
Xina.
No sé, no sé.
Si passés això seria bastant drama, eh?
Però tinc un plaer. Si això
passa, tinc un plaer per no haver de
abandonar aquesta part del viatge.
Però, bueno, esperem que
això no arribi. Una altra cosa
que passarà és que em veuré d'hora
més de tres hores,
crec. O sigui, Xina té l'hora única.
Tothom, tota la Xina,
que és molt gran, la Xina, segueix
l'horari de Beijing. Beijing està
molt lluny d'aquí, però
molt lluny d'aquí, molt, molt, molt.
És a dir,
no sé,
Samarkand
està molt més a prop que aquí,
que Beijing, no? Fins i tot
Almaty, Kazakhstan,
està molt més a prop de
Thaisnogar, d'aquesta, de Kulmapass,
que Beijing. Però la Xina té
l'horari a tota
el país el mateix. Llavors, clar,
és molt louc perquè
aquí, si surt el sol a les sis del matí,
per dir alguna cosa,
a Hora Tajika,
a la part xinesa, que surt el sol
immediatament a la mateixa
hora, no? Però, si comptes
l'horari de Beijing, doncs són
tres
hores més. Per tant,
diria que és això, eh?
Ara que no em liï. Diria que surt a les nou
del matí. O surt a
les tres de la matinada. Ai, ara no ho tinc clar. Però,
bé, no. Que, clar, posen uns horaris
que no tenen cap mena de
sentit. Ara encara, no? Però, ara,
a determinades èpoques de l'any,
no ho sé. Bueno.
Thaisnogar,
que és la ciutat on he d'anar,
està a 60 quilòmetres
de la frontera amb
la Xina. O sigui, demà el que passarà, ja us
ho explicaré també, eh? Però, quan arribi a la frontera
de la Xina, m'obligaran a agafar
un transport per baixar fins a Lavall.
No em deixaran fer aquí tramar a peu.
I des de Lavall fins a Thaisnogar hi ha 60
quilòmetres.
Els faré a peu. És la teoria.
Demà, bueno, no sé. Ja veurem a veure si em deixen.
Doncs aquesta és la ciutat
més a l'oest de tota la Xina.
Curiós, eh? Curiós.
Per si algú encara no s'ha enterat,
la Xina, jo no començaré a viatjar
per la Xina. Ja, a veure, què tal la Xina? No, no.
Jo vaig des d'aquí fins a la frontera amb Pakistan,
que és pocs quilòmetres
i no visitaré la Xina.
Visitaré aquesta ciutat que es diu Thaisnogar,
que deu ser una ciutat molt de pas,
molt de camioner, molt de viatger
i no sé fins a quin punt
tindrà coses típiques xineres o algo així.
Ho descobrirem.
I també una altra cosa,
hi ha l'última,
dues últimes que passaran demà, és que deixo Centràsia.
Centràsia es considera
que és Tajikistan,
Kazakstan, Kirgistan i Uzbekistan.
Aquests quatre països. Depèn de la definició
que busquis, no? Però,
es considera aquests quatre països, per tant,
demà
acabo aquest tram
del viatge que ha sigut
molt intens.
I per últim, una cosa
molt important, que potser l'hauria de dir la primera,
que és que demà canvio de
conca hidrogràfica. És a dir,
tots els rius que estan en aquesta
zona on estem ara, si tu ara tires una gota
aquí, aquesta gota
acaba al mar Caspi.
Tots els rius d'aquí acaben
al mar Caspi. En canvi,
quan passi el pas
de culma,
tots els rius d'aquella zona
ja no acaben al mar Caspi, sinó que acaben,
crec, a l'oceà Índic.
No me la vull jugar, però crec que és l'oceà
Índic. O és el Pacífic.
Diria que és l'Índic. Això ho hauria
mirat abans, eh?
Bueno, algun comentari
ho pot escriure.
Doncs això, demà
és un dia molt important,
canvien moltes coses. Després tornaré entre Pakistan,
que al final
tindrà més semblances amb Tajikistan
que la Xina. Però bueno,
tu,
aquests canvis molen especialment perquè, ostres,
ja porto molt de temps a Tajikistan
i, a pesar que està guai,
doncs sí, un canvi està bé.
Bueno, tu,
doncs vaig a escoltar el Barça,
que ja està guanyant 2 a 0.
És molt louco perquè estic aquí, al mig del
no-re. O sigui, ara estic al cul
del món. Literalment,
al cul del món.
I puc escoltar el Barça.
Ja va en marxa.
Vinga, bona nit.
Demà dia gran.